arlo is in dallas hi carlo welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hello mr ramsay mr holland thank you for
having me in your show
sure what's up i have a quick question
so my wife and i um
we're about to celebrate our five year
anniversary
um and we we are worried about like
whether
do we do it do we not do it we are
currently in our master's program both
of us
we are having our job and we have some
student loans from this program but
other than that we don't have really any
other debt
so our main question is like do we do
this trip or do we hold off until we
are done oh so you want to go on a trip
yeah mm-hmm well if you're working our
system you're in baby step two getting
out of debt
no trips you can do whatever you want to
do you're an adult you get to decide
but you don't go out to eat no you don't
go on trips nope and
you you you don't do anything you
scorched earth you get rid of the dead
and uh you can go on a trip around the
block celebrate with a cut drop
celebrate with a cupcake
yeah you drive around and then you come
back home and go boy that was fun
and we're going to get back to business
because in another year or two
we're going to have this stuff out of
our lives and we're going to get a raise
we didn't have to go talk to anybody
we're going to get a raise and we're
going to be able to move forward and
protect ourselves
carla you can go on anywhere you want to
go when you get out of debt because
you're not going to be broke anymore you
can do whatever you want to do sir
you're a grown person you get to make
your choices
the reason we teach the things we teach
is because they
work this way and the singular focus
intensity intensity
that does not even allow you to ask this
question
kind of intensity is what will get you
out of debt you can wander into debt you
can't wander out
you can't just sort of well i think i
can do this and do this and do this
and and then 10 years later you're still
fighting the exact same crap
and sally may still set up with a pup
tent in the back bedroom
and you aren't going to get her out of
there because she is
she's ornery you are not going to get
sally mae out of your life unless you
are
really angry and intense
and focused and that does not allow for
these other things again that's what has
the highest probability of getting you
out of debt
which then gives you the highest
probability of building wealth
and that's what this formula is about uh
and so it's live like no one else
so that later you can live and give like
no one else no
no discipline seems pleasant at the time
the bible says
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
now again you do whatever you want to do
sir but if you're asking what we teach
and what we suggest and what we have
done the way you get out of debt
is scorched earth vacation does not even
come
up in this discussion and carlo you
could use this as a great opportunity to
fast forward things
meaning talk about the places you all
want to go on that trip in a couple
years
print out some pictures go look online
use it as a motivating factor of
what other job can we do what other
income can we bring in to go faster
because really the thing standing
between you and this trip is the debt
in your emergency fund so how fast are
you willing to run
what are you willing to sacrifice how
bad do y'all want to go on that trip
and i'm going to tell you i've talked to
couples and they've made some serious
sacrifices
to make some stuff happen quicker you
guys can do that too
yeah you know chris i was getting ready
i was working on a real estate deal the
other day
and i was all emotionally involved in i
was pumped about it
and that's rare for you then the deal
fell apart oh
and you know i had this weird experience
because i didn't put that money
on that i felt richer
because i didn't spend the money i
didn't spend it so when you don't spend
the money on this vacation you should
feel richer
hmm you kept your money yeah yeah
got options now that was a weird
experience i had not really
had because that's not the way my brain
usually works but it's very interesting